Candid Truth.
>> What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth. We're going to
get candid with it. I want to get really
candid because
it's been a while since we went live.
You know, a couple nights ago, I went
live interviewing Diego about his
testimony coming out of the transgender
movement. And before that, it was like
10 days before our previous live. And
even the live that was uh the New Year's
live about the phoenix coming out of the
ashes and and this ritual ceremony that
happened on the New Year's, but it was
actually uh a little bit longer than I
wanted even for that video to come out.
And um you know, it's just been hard.
I've been in kind of this funk, this
rut, just lack of motivation. And it's
like I got all these ideas that I I want
to share with people that God's
impressed upon my heart. I got at least
three videos lined up that are coming
out. But I just want to be open and
honest with you guys. Like
this stuff really starts to weigh down
on you when you see what God is showing
you. when you get to see through the
veil, when you have spiritual
discernment and you really see the signs
of the times and how how few Christians
actually see it and are living it and
are living like it's here and just like
the Bible says about the days of Noah,
they're eating and drinking and marrying
and giving in marriage. And it's almost
like, are these words falling on deaf
ears or do people just not know what to
do?
You know, I we're in the situation where
we're trying to figure out like what do
we do? Because
I feel like Christ's return is so soon.
And I I'm not a date setter. I'm not a
prophet,
but I've talked to you guys about this
before. I believe that this is the year,
2026. I believe this is the year that we
will be told we are not alone. That
there are beings and we are
communicating with them. They've already
tell they're already telling us that
they communicate with non-human
intelligences. So, me and Aubrey have
just really been thinking realistically
like what are we supposed to do? What
are we going to do? Do we have a plan?
What's our plan? You know, we live in a
three-bedroom house that we're still
making payments on.
We have we had a garden for the past 2
years, but we're not like canning.
There's just a lot to think about. And
uh I think by the end of this
presentation you guys will also believe
that we are very close to the end.
Whether Jesus comes next year or 10
years or 50 years from now, the signs of
the times are here. The beast system has
been set up. The stage is set for Satan
to appear as a cosmic Christ, a
supernatural being that's going to
deceive the entire world and deceive
people by means of those miracles. It
says, "So this is how they work or out
of chaos. There have been fires in
Canada, California, Hawaii, Australia.
Fires everywhere, right? Storms and
hurricanes with record destruction,
floods displacing thousands, riots and
political unrest, economic instability,
mental health crisis and digital
fatigue.
This is all by design.
Satan has a plan. Order out of chaos.
Create the chaos, bring about the
solution, bring about the order. It's
the Hegelian dialectic. He plays both
sides create the chaos
and create a solution. So these fires I
don't believe are natural. These storms,
these floods I don't believe are
natural.
um the mental health crisis and the
digital fatigue and all this. This is
all because of the bombardment of
uh technology and how much we have on
our plate. You know, you think about a
day-to-day life in the life of a pilgrim
or like the Little House on the Prairie
days, it was like wake up to the rooster
crowing and go out and cut down some
trees for firewood. um tend to the
garden, play with the kids,
school them from home, which would
probably be like teaching them how to
cook, how to um
you know, do chores and things like this
and of course to read and all that kind
of stuff. But life was a lot slower, a
lot different. Now it's like, wait a
minute, I have 10 messages on Facebook.
I got to get to the email. I gotta work
on a keynote presentation for that live
I'm supposed to do. And you got all this
stuff in your mind. And then you top it
off with wait, are you preparing for the
end? Do you have a garden going? Do you
have land? Are you fleeing to the
mountains?
So there's a lot going on and all of us
are bombarded with the mental fatigue of
dealing with the thoughts of all this
stuff, right? And then top it off with
5G, smart meters, cell phone signals.
Who knows what this stuff's doing to us?
We don't even know what a microwave is
doing to us. We are the generation of
microwaves, smart meters, cell phones,
Wi-Fi, 5G bombardment. Right? I've seen
more people die of strokes than I've
ever seen in my entire life than I've
ever even heard of. Strokes, heart
attacks.
People are just dropping left and right.
It's
I don't think it's an accident.
Here's some proof that there have been
um more wildfires now than than ever.
You know, NASA's talking about this.
Over over the past 20 years, the amount
of land area burnt each year has
increased as wildfires have grown
larger, while the number of fires each
year has remained fairly constant.
climate change. You know, they're always
going to blame it on climate change. I
know what climate change is. It's those
antennas out there in Antarctica. But it
says, "The most damaging hurricanes in
the United States are now occurring
three times more often than they did a
century ago. And since 1980,
the proportion of major hurricanes in
the Atlantic Ocean have doubled.
As ocean and air temperatures continue
to rise, the risk associated with
hurricanes only grow more severe. So
yeah, maybe temperatures are rising when
you're blasting the atmosphere with
these highowered emissions, but I don't
believe in climate change. I don't I
believe in cyclical things that are
happening. I believe in man-made climate
change. Yeah. Uh the climate change is
all the time. You know, they they used
to call it when I was growing up
watching Captain Planet and all that,
they used to call it global warming, but
people caught on that it's not getting
hotter every year. So, they had to
change it to climate change because you
can't argue that the climate changes. It
does.
Um, the next one says, "A warmer world
means increasing evaporation, which
supercharges storms and produces more
rain, resulting in higher chances of
flooding in the United States." Nine of
the 10 years for extreme one-day
precipitation have occurred since 1995.
Wow. And this other um Google result
said, "Yes, data from various sources
show a significant and ongoing rise in
mental illness and distress, especially
among youth. The increases in anxiety,
depression and related issues like
suicide and a trend exasperated
but not solely co caused by covid-19
pandemic linked to factors like digital
media, social pressures and improved
awareness globally in the United
globally and the US mental disorders are
climbing in prevalence and impact though
some data
also suggest improved diagnosis rates
due to reduced stigma and better access
to care, making the picture complex.
Now, we live in a generation where
people kind of embrace their mental
disorder. They're like, "Oh, yeah. I'm
I'm ADHD and bipolar and uh depressed."
It's kind of like they they really wear
it like a badge of honor. And I'm not
mocking anyone that deals with those
things. It's it's a shame that so much
of mental illness is going on right now,
but it's due to our environment. It's
due to all this technology and
everything. We shouldn't embrace these
things as if it's something cool. You
know, I think this generation really
kind of puts another notch in their belt
like I got another mental illness and
it's something to kind of brag about.
The infrastructure is already set up for
the beast system. Look, it's not like
coming anymore. It's not like the beast
system is coming. It's here. The beast
system is here and all it takes is for a
couple little laws to be tweaked here
and there. And mark of the beast is
here. AI governance is already in the
works. When Trump was talking about
Stargate,
they were talking about AI governance
the first day that Trump was in office.
Then they kind of stopped talking about
that and now November 24, I think it was
November 24, he launched Genesis mission
which was the same thing. It's a AI
governance where AI is linked in to all
the nuclear power plants and the uh
science labs and all that stuff and it's
pushing us towards singularity.
Singularity is going to be the endgame.
All right, digital currency and the
elimination of cash. I know this doesn't
sound like a big deal, but last year,
the end of the year, we eliminated the
penny. That might not sound like a big
deal, like, oh, it's a penny, big deal.
Who cares? That's one step towards
eliminating cash. What happened during
COVID? There were signs that said no
cash accepted, right? Because everybody
was afraid to touch the money.
What if we reach a place where it's just
like it's more convenient to go digital?
I mean, think about it. You don't have
to run printing presses. You don't have
to cut down trees. You don't have to use
special ink and try to um put all these
different watermarks in there that make
it hard to counterfeit. Just go all
digital. It makes it so much easier. The
click of a mouse, you're you're
transferring money. You're receiving
money. Way more convenient. Right.
That's right around the corner. We're
going to find that out. Universal basic
income is what Elon Musk has been
talking about. We're going to look into
what that is. 5G surveillance and smart
tech, social credit behavior system, and
control through convenience. That's
what's going to push everybody into
doing this. Convenience has been our
demise for years. We say, "Oh, it's more
convenient to do this." And that becomes
a trap. It's like a Trojan horse. So
check this out. I'm going to like walk
us through something in history to show
that history repeats itself. We believe
this. We understand this. History
repeats itself. And are we seeing a
repeat of what happened a long time ago.
And where is that going to lead us? So I
was asking Google a lot of questions for
this presentation. And it says, "Yes,
the Great Depression was the primary
catalyst pushing the US government to
pass the Social Security Act in 1935.
Before 1935, people didn't have a Social
Security number. They didn't have a
Social Security card. There was no
Social Security Act before 1935. That
wasn't that long ago. There's probably
people alive today, actually. Yeah,
people alive today that were alive in
1935,
they'd be 91 years old. Um, my wife's
grandma is
93, 98, I can't remember. She was alive
when this happened.
So that social security number that you
have and that card that you have
was pushed by the Great Depression
creating a federal safety net. So there
was a reason they did it. There was a a
crisis
and that crisis was able to push people
to all conform.
Okay. As conspiracy theorists, I think a
lot of us believe that there's a lot of
manufactured crisises, right?
That when I see a crisis on television,
my antenna already go up. I'm like, um,
is there anything sketchy about this?
Does this line up with the official
story? And more times than not, when I
really analyze, when I set my emotions
aside and I don't think about, oh, is
this politically correct? And I look at
that thing like I'm a detective. Things
don't add up with the official story.
And it it's from 911 to Sandy Hook to
Charlie Kirk. All these things you're
going to find things that don't line up
with the official story.
Which makes me wonder what agenda are
they trying to push. It's order out of
chaos. Order out of chaos. That's the
method.
So, what were the key causes that even
created the Great Depression? And I say
created the Great Depression for a
reason because I believe it was
manufactured. But look what it says.
Stock market crash of 1929.
You know that you can make the stock
market crash.
You know that you can create these
crises. You can create um inflation and
people can't afford things anymore. All
right. Bank failure and panics.
Monetary policy mistakes. The Federal
Reserve failed to expand the money
supply and stop bank failures, worsening
deflation and credit contraction. And I
want you to pay attention to this. High
tariffs intended to protect US
industries. It triggered retaliatory
tariffs collapsing world trade. Are you
paying attention to this? High tariffs
and it was supposed to protect the US
industry. They thought it was a good
idea to raise the tariffs. What do you
think's going on right now? What do you
think has already happened the end of
last year? During his second term as
president of the United States, Donald
Trump enacted a series of steep tariffs
affecting nearly all goods imported into
the country. From January to April 2025,
the overall average effective US tariff
rate rose from 2.5%
to as high as 27%,
the highest level in over a century.
What was part of the cause of the Great
Depression? High tariffs.
I don't think this timing is just
coincidence. All right. Trump's tariffs
trigger rising rate of job layoffs. This
is CNBC talking about job layoffs
because of Trump's high tariffs. AI
washing and massive layoffs hitting the
economy.
It's talking about more than 60,000 jobs
cut this year. More than 60,000 jobs.
Now, this article came out in November
of last year.
You realize that AI doubles its thinking
power. It evolves basically like every
three months. Every moment it is
evolving itself and getting better and
better and better. The AI images and
videos that we laughed at a year ago, we
can't even tell what's real anymore. We
have to like really like I'm starting to
look and be like, is this real? Is this
AI? And I'm I'm starting to question
real videos and believe AI videos if I'm
honest now. I I have a little bit
sharper eye for it because I play with
it a lot. But for people that have never
been exposed to it, they're going to
believe a lot of stuff. And believe me,
the technology that they give us, the
elites give us to play with is 10 to 20
years behind what they have. Okay. Um
this is on CNBC. It says announced US
job cuts. These are by years. You got
July 2023, July 2024, July 2025. What in
the world is happening? 2023, 2024,
2025. Wham!
Look at that number. 946,426
announced US job cuts.
This is insane. This is the world that
we are living in right now and people
are just playing like oh just
eat, drink, given marriage, all that
stuff. The days of Noah.
What was the next thing? Reduced demand
and overp production. Consumers couldn't
afford goods leading to layoffs which
further reduced spending. Is that
happening today?
Do you think that's happening today? I
literally copied and paste that and I
asked Google, I said, "Is this happening
today?" And I pasted, "Consumers
couldn't afford goods." Blah, blah. Look
what it said. Yes. The cycle of
consumers struggling with affordability
leading to reduced spending and
businesses responding with cost cutting
and layoffs often citing AI or weak
demand is happening now late 2025 early
creating concerns about a potential
contraction or recession with many
Americans even higher income earners
cutting back on big purchases and
falling behind on bills like utilities.
It's saying even people with the
highpaying jobs are suffering. You know
why? More actually more so because what
are the highest paying jobs? Things like
lawyers, things like accountants. These
are the jobs that are getting taken over
by AI more so than your physical labor
job. Your uh your carpenter, your
plumber. AI isn't unclogging your drain.
AI isn't building a house yet. The
people that are making the big bucks,
the computer jobs, are losing their
jobs.
So, what's happening when people have
less money to spend because groceries
are really expensive right now? They're
spending less on
luxury things. So, businesses are having
to close down. Layoffs are happening.
I want to I want to go back and look at
this because we're looking at some key
points here. Stock market crash, bank
failures, monetary policy mistakes. We
have high tariffs is definitely
happening. Reduced demands of over produ
and overp production is definitely
happening.
Unequal wealth distribution.
A small percentage of the population
held most wealth limiting overall
purchasing power. That's definitely
happening. gold standard tied global
currencies transmitting the US dturn
worldwide and hindering monetary policy
responses. I got to admit that's kind of
over my head. I don't keep up with
what's going on with gold and all that
stuff.
History is repeating itself.
Key indicators of this cycle. It went on
to to expound
affordability crisis. Roughly half of
Americans find it harder to afford
groceries. Half of Americans find it
harder to afford groceries and many are
falling behind on essential bills like
utilities due to rising cost,
slowing demand and layoffs. Businesses
particularly in tech and manufactur.
See, this is what I'm talking about. in
tech and manufacturing
are reporting weakened demand and
cutting jobs partly due to higher cost
tariff impacts and efficiency drives
including AI implementation. So there's
a couple factors here. You got higher
higher tariffs well partly due to higher
cost
uh tariff impacts
efficiency drives including AI. These
are the things that are happening in our
world right now
that are ultimately going to lead to
this second great depression. This is
the impending doom that is coming. It's
everybody can feel it. Whether you're a
believer, whether you're a Christian or
an atheist, you can see the signs of the
times. Just look, just research. Just
look at history and look how it's
repeating itself. Listen to these big
tech guys what they're saying. How Elon
Musk is saying we need a universal basic
income. We're gonna get into all this
stuff.
Economic cycle. Oh, reduced spending.
Reduced spending. Consumers are pulling
back on non-essentials
and big ticket purchases. And sentiment
surveys show increasing economic anxiety
even among higher inome households. Even
the people that are making the most
money are not able to make their bills.
Economic cycle concerns. This pattern of
reduction demands layoffs and lower
spending aligns with the contraction
phase of a business cycle raising fears
of recession. In essence, the situation
you described is a recognized economic
trend currently impacting the US economy
as of late 2025 and early 2026 with
consumer pullback and business cost
cutting reinforcing each other.
So then I asked another question. Yes,
there is a significant push in America
towards digital IDs
driven by states adopting mobile
drivers, federal interest and streamline
streamlining identity verification,
improving digital identity act, the
private sector demand a and private
sector demand for efficient identity
proofing. Though this movement faces
concerns from p privacy activists or
advocates about potential tracking and
equity issues as detailed by
organizations like the ACLU
h this is a.gov website. I didn't show
the toolbar up there or the URL but it's
a.gov gov and it says nextg
FCW lawmakers want government to promote
use of digital IDs.
At the bottom you can see it says um the
concept of digital IDs is relatively
straightforward. Individuals would store
their verified personal identification
documents on their phones or in an app.
Supporters of this supporters of the
approach say that it would provide
consumers and businesses with more
confidence in the veracity of
transactions and interactions,
particularly for those conducted online.
Maybe you don't see the harm in this.
Let me explain something to you.
We live in a day where you really can't
survive without a phone. Think about if
you were trying to go off-rid and you're
like, "I'm not going to have a phone.
I'm not going to have an email. I'm not
going to have a phone number. Obviously,
I'm not going to have a computer." Okay.
Try to go to work. Try try to go to
dollar general and ask, "Hey, I'd like
to apply for the job." Okay. Um, you
just go to dollar.com.
Well, I don't have a phone. Oh, you
don't have a phone? Um,
well, we got a computer in the corner
over there. Okay. So, you go to the
computer. You're filling out the
application and then it's like
um it's got an asterk by the num by the
blank that says phone number. Well, you
don't have a phone number. What are you
going to put there? Well, maybe I'll put
my my relatives phone number. All right.
And it's going to say email. There's an
asterk by that, too. You have to have an
email. You have to have a phone to even
function in this world today. And they
do it with the convenience aspect. You
go to a restaurant, you want to save 15%
off that meal. Oh, all you got to do is
scan the little QR code. Oh, I don't
have a phone. Oh, well, can I get the
15% off anyway? Well, no, you have to
scan the QR code. You don't have a
phone? No, I don't have a phone. This is
the world we live in right now. It's
like almost impossible to function
without a phone. Imagine when everything
goes digital. Because if you do get the
job, if you do get the job and you
really want to be off-rid and they say,
"Okay, um, well, we're going to pay you
this much and it'll be direct deposited
to your bank." What What bank do you
bank with? Well, I don't I don't have a
bank. I don't trust banks. I just, you
know, I just cash my check at the
grocery store and I I store the money
up. Oh, no. We don't do checks. We don't
write checks. It's direct deposit. You
have to have a bank. Wait, I have to
have a bank. Okay. Now try to go to the
bank, open up a bank account without a
phone, without an email. It gets nuts.
This is crazy. This is already the world
we live in currently. Currently, it is
rapidly changing. It's rapidly. They are
pushing for the one ID, the digital ID.
So why? Because right now you can say,
"Oh, I got like four different email
accounts and I use this email for this.
You know, I pay my bill with this email.
I I use this phone number over here. We
don't really have like a a one
identification digitally. I you know I
got multiple email accounts. I got
Facebook and you could have multiple
Facebooks and all that stuff. There you
you are out there in many different
facets.
What the digital ID will do is make you
have a one identification just like your
ID card. when you get pulled over or
something, you're not going to pull out
your Engles card or your Food City card,
you have to pull out your driver's
license. That's the only thing that's
acceptable, driver's license or
passport. But there's only one form of
acceptable ID, right? You can't use your
student ID. You can't use your library
card. It has to be your driver's license
or passport. The same is going to happen
with the digital ID. It's an app and
it's for everything.
All the money will be digital very soon.
Everybody's going to get a universal
basic income and you have to have the
app. You have to have the phone or you
do not survive. You don't get to spend
money. And so every transaction you make
will be from your digital ID. You go to
a grocery store, boop. You pay for it
with your phone. You you got to pay your
water bill, boop. Uh your electricity,
boop. Everything is tied into that. And
when Trump's dream of AI governance
happens, and it's not just Trump, it's
the elites, it's Satan who's at the top.
When his dream of the allseeing eye of
AI governance is watching every moment
of every day,
then the moment you go five over the
speed limit,
deduction from your bank.
the moment you do something immoral
because
there's not going to be jobs anymore.
Your income is going to be based on
behavior.
You do good things, you get money. You
do bad things, the money goes away.
We're going to get into that. I don't
want to get ahead of myself.
>> [snorts]
>> Digital IDs in the USA are electronic
versions of physical IDs like driver's
license on smartphones allowing secure
convenient verification for services and
travel with states like Arizona,
California, Colorado, Georgia, and I
think that's Maryland. issuing them for
TSA and other uses via apps like Apple
Wallet, Google Wallet and state specific
apps. While still developing,
they offer enhanced privacy through
biometrics, which is Face ID and Touch
ID, but raise privacy concerns for some
about data trafficking. Though the TSA
says they don't build national
databases. So, you know, we can trust
TSA, right? They're they have our best
interest just like the government.
They're for us, right? No, not true.
Mobile driver's license, MDL, digital
versions of stateisssued licenses stored
securely on phones and read
electronically. Digital wallets. So,
it's going to be your driver's license.
It's going to be your money. Digital
wallet apps like Apple Wallet and Google
Wallet support adding eligible
MDLs or even US passports for domestic
travel. U notes the TSA. So it's your
ID, it's your passport, it's your
wallet, it's your money.
Security uses encryption and biometrics.
Oh, goody. Face scan and Touch ID. your
thumbrint and your face scan for
authentication,
ensuring only the user presents the ID.
So, they're going to present this to you
as safe and secure. This is a way that
nobody can steal your money because it's
not paper money that could be robbed
from you. It's not a credit card that
could be stolen from you. It's on your
phone and the only person that can open
your phone is your face or your touch.
This is how they're going to sell it to
you.
Convenience speeds up processes like
airport security and age verification at
some venues. State specific programs
vary by state. Many states have offer
digital IDs through their own apps like
LA wallet or major uh digital wallets.
So, we're taking back taking this back
to the Great Depression. This was a sad
scene where you just saw people lined up
for miles. I thought this was just in
America. When I looked this up, it said
that this Great Depression affected the
world, which is crazy to think about.
Somehow
the stock market crashing and all these
things that were key components to this
affected the entire world where people
were lined up to get their soup and
their bread
and they were given these things right
here called food stamps. Notice they
look just like a stamp. Like you like
like you tear off to put on a uh an
envelope. And the mail they were
literally stamps back then. And the blue
one was for food and the orange one was
for luxury items. But there was
something you had to do to get the food
stamps. Now the food stamps were created
to make some kind of method of universal
basic income. Nobody had jobs. Nobody
could get a job. Nobody could get money
to eat. So they created these food
stamps. Universal basic income. Okay,
think about that. This is a parallel. I
asked what direction are food stamps
going? Are they going digital? It says
yes. Food stamps snap are increasingly
connected to digital systems. moving
from traditional EBT cards to using
mobile apps for uh managing benefits,
locking, unlocking cards and
participating in mobile payment pilots
with digital ID authentication
for security. Though the physical EBT
card with a PIN remains the primary
access method for most users, states are
implementing modernized
like wait. States are implementing
modernizations like chip cards and
mobile payments requiring digital
identity proofing during online
applications and for app access to
prevent fraud. Now look, they're telling
you to prevent fraud, we must move to a
digital ID system. You know, people are
lying and they're getting food stamps
and they're trading them and all this
stuff. To combat this, the only way you
can get food stamp now is you have to
nope. You got to go through the digital
ID. That's the only way. If do you want
your food stamps or not? Get the digital
ID. Get the app. We need to know. We
need to scan your face and have
biometrics and that's the only way
you're going to get your food stamps. I
know you're suffering. I know your kids
can't eat. Get the app. What are you
tripping on? Get the digital ID. This is
how it's going to operate. Convenience
and through a crisis
like mass layoffs. It's already
happening. Hundreds of thousands of
people have lost their jobs because of
tariffs that are going up just like the
Great Depression because of AI taking
over jobs
and they're speaking of universal basic
income. How SNAP is digitizing EBT
cards. The core system uses electronic
benefit transfer EBT cards similar to
debit cards loaded with benefits. Mobile
apps. Users can manage accounts via apps
like Edge or EBT edge or connect EBT to
check balances, change pins, and lock
and unlock cards for security between
purchases. Digital authentication for
online applications
and app access. States use digital
identity verification and
authentication,
sometimes requiring a valid photo ID to
prove eligibility. Mobile payments
pilots in states like Illinois,
Massachusetts, and Oklahoma are testing
using smartphones for SNAP purchases,
moving away from the physical card. All
right, you see that fourth bullet point,
mobile payment. We are moving away from
the physical card to using your mobile
phone.
Chip technology modernizing EBT cards
with chips makes them more secure
against skimming and fraud and major
focus uh for the USDA.
So it says in summary food stamps are
not fully replaced by a single digital
ID. Rather they are a blend of physical
EBT cards and digital tools, apps,
online portals for convenience and
security. Man, this sounds so biblical.
Convenient peace and security.
For convenience and security with
digital identity proofing becoming
standard for access and fraud
prevention. This is what they're telling
you. If you want to feed your family,
you must get the app. You must get the
digital ID. It's the only way. There's
too much fraud out there. There's too
much identity theft out there. You have
to get the digital ID. It's the only way
you can eat. Are you catching on? Are
you following the train of thought here?
This is just like the Great Depression.
They manufactured a depression with high
tariffs and stock market collapse and
all this stuff to the point where
everyone was lining up for food and they
said, "Look, you want to eat?" Well,
here's you some universal basic income
stamps. Here's your stamp. Here's you a
stamp. Food stamps. Welfare.
It's happening again.
Only this time, it's all digital.
You want to eat? I know you got laid
off. I know AI replaced your job. We're
going to help you. We are the
government. We're going to help you.
It's welfare. Get the digital ID. Stop
refusing this. Get the digital ID and
make your life easy. Feed your family.
Get the digital ID. This is a website
digital authentication
and identity proofing and supplemental
nutrition assistance program which is
SNAP applications. So this is a website
right here telling you that this is all
about to be digital. This is all about
to be your digital identity, your
digital ID that the UK was forcing and
now America is pushing for it. This is
going to be just like China's social
credit score. What is China's social
credit system? A broad government
initiative to build trustworthiness in
society. They're talking about that all
the time, right? We need peace. We need
unity. Peace and safety. Trump has said,
"I'm going to bring peace and security
to the whole world. We're going to be in
the golden age. Everyone's going to have
prosperity. Everyone's going to be
getting along with peace and security."
Right? This is what he's talking about
right here. A broad government
initiative to build trustworthiness in
society by monitoring and rating the
financial, social, and legal behavior of
individuals and businesses. Using
rewards like easier loans for good
behavior and punishments like travel
bans for bad behavior. Though it's a
fragmented system of blacklist,
financial reports, and local pilots
rather than one single universal score,
the goal is to enforce contracts, curb
fraud. That's what we're talking about
right now, curb fraud, and encourage
civilized conduct,
primarily impacting corporate
compliance, but also affecting
individual access to services like
loans, education, and travel. Somebody
might be hearing this and be like,
"Look, what's wrong with getting along?
What's wrong with people being
civilized? Why do you act like this is a
bad thing?" Because who makes the rules?
Who's to say that you're civilized or
not? Who sets the moral code? Maybe
believing that there's only one way to
heaven is univilized. Maybe believing
that Jesus is the only way to the father
is univilized. may be saying that
homosexuality is a sin is is univilized.
You see what I'm talking about here?
There there are people out there, the
elites, the rulers of this world. They
want to create a one world religion, a
coexist movement where every road leads
to God. It doesn't matter if you're a
Satanist, a Buddhist, a Muslim, a Jew,
you're all going to heaven. We need to
all get along, sing kumbaya, and
coexist. And there's going to be a one
world church for that. And if you go to
that church, there's going to be a lot
of indoctrination and brainwashing to
make you a tolerant person. And if you
do it, you're you're going to get some
good basic income. You're going to be
able to feed your family if you go to
that church. But if you don't, it's
going to be a struggle. You reject going
to the good church of love, man. How you
going to eat this week?
You're going to do a lot of humanitarian
things. It's going to be a struggle. If
you try to buck the system, it's going
to be hard. What are we doing to
prepare? What are we doing? Are we
growing food? Are we trying to build a
tiny home in the mountains? I know it
sounds impossible. I know it's hard.
We're trying to think through this stuff
ourselves. I'm just telling you what's
been on our minds lately, that the
Bible's real. Prophecy is true. It's
happening. What are we going to do about
it? What is the next step of action?
How the social credit system works? Data
aggregation. Data comes from various
sources including financial reports.
Wow. Court judgments, tax filings,
social behavior like charitable giving
or online posts. Are you catching this?
Online posts. I didn't even think to
mention that. But imagine if you can't
say what you believe on social media.
You're not allowed to say, "I don't
agree with this law. I don't agree that
two men should be able to be married. I
don't agree that a child should have his
genitals chopped off." These are things
that you're not going to be allowed to
say on social media because it could
blacklist you and you're not able to get
your basic universal income.
Blacklist and whitelist. The most
prominent aspect involves blacklisting
entities, companies, or individuals for
serious offenses like failing court
orders or significant pollution
restricting their access to certain
services.
Interesting. So now you have to have a
Tesla. You have to have a a smart car
with cameras all over it, microphones,
and and it is self-driving and could
literally drive you to a internment camp
if it wants to because the oldfashioned
cars, the gas powered cars, they're
polluting. Oh, you're going to get
blacklisted for that. Rewards and
punishments. High-scoring individuals or
compliant businesses might get benefits
like faster visa processing or easier
loans while low scores face restrictions
on high-end consumption planes, luxury
hotels or public services. Not one
single score. Contrary to popular
belief, there isn't one single national
score for every citizen. It's a
collection of systems with local
governments and various agencies running
pilot programs focusing heavily on
corporate trustworthiness.
Key goals is to improve governance to
increase order and accountability in
markets and society. Sounds great,
right? To increase order. What kind of
order? The new world order. Enforce
trust to encourage honest behavior and
make it easier to identify untrustworthy
actors. Examples of behaviors tracked,
especially in pilots. Negative, failing
to pay debts, serious traffic
violations, business fraud, excessive
pollution. Positive, donating to
charity, volunteer work, paying taxes on
time, business compliance.
Now, I know that we all have to pay
taxes, but man, that is robbery. And
they're like, "You better pay your taxes
on time or you will get a bad social
credit score." This is in the current
news two weeks ago, one month ago, and
it says, "A future without work." What
Elon Musk, Bill Gates, and others in AI
are saying about the future. What are
they saying? They're saying that in the
future when AI really takes over, work
is going to be more like uh a hobby.
Elon Musk said you can go to the grocery
store and get vegetables or you can grow
them in your garden. Yeah, growing
vegetables is a lot harder, but some
people like to do it. He said that's how
work is going to be. It's going to be
optional. Do you want to work just
because you're bored? You're not going
to have to work. universal basic income,
but it's not just going to be freely
given. It's not like, oh yeah, we just
always give everyone the same amount of
money. It's the golden age. Everybody's
rich. No, there's going to be rewards
and punishment for being a good moral
citizen. Elon Musk says universal high
income is coming. Elon Musk predicts
universal high income will pay for
everything. How much would you get? Elon
Musk says universal income is
inevitable. Why? He thinks that's a bad
thing.
So, this isn't just me jumping to
conclusions saying, "Oh, you know what?
I I think it could be based off of
social credit systems, you know, social
score and all that." No, the the AI
governance that's already here now as of
November of last year with Genesis
mission, the AI governance is its whole
task is to make sure that you are a good
citizen. Watch these clips.
>> Jobs to Texas. The president stood next
to the CEOs of Open AI, Oracle, and Soft
Bank to announce a 500 billion dollar
project called Stargate. The project
would build new data centers and
electricity generation needed to power
AI. Texas will serve as a launch point
with the first of the data centers being
built in Abalene. The goal for Stargate
is to create 100,000 new jobs here in
the United States.
>> So that was his first day back in
office. Now you haven't really heard
much about Stargate because I think
maybe people freaked out. I don't know.
I don't know why they're not talking
about Stargate, but now it's not
something we voted on. It's here.
Genesis mission. Go watch our video. Go
in our live tabs. Scroll until you see
the picture of a a Terminator. And it's
called the Genesis Mission. It's here.
It's already here, guys. Omniresent AI
cameras will ensure good behavior.
This is America. This is not a Chinese
ad. This is not a Chinese newspaper.
Omniresent AI cameras will ensure good
behavior says Ellison. This is the guy
who runs the thing. He owns Oracle. Here
he is. Larry Ellison predicts rise of
modern surveillance state where citizens
will be on their best behavior. So this
is all about enforcing good behavior in
America. This is not China, guys.
Oracle co-founder Larry Ellison predicts
AI surveillance will be part of our
everyday lives in the future. During a
recent Oracle Q&A, Ellison said AI will
soon play a major role in monitoring
society through a vast network of
interconnected cameras, including
security systems, police body cams, and
vehicle dash cams.
>> Everyone would see it. Your your your
body cams will be transmitting that. The
police will be on their best behavior
because we rec we're constantly
recording, watching and recording
everything that's going on. Citizens
will be on their best behavior because
we're constantly recording and reporting
everything that's going on.
>> Ellison's vision is for AI to analyze
data from this network of cameras in
real time in an attempt to prevent crime
while also tracking and influencing
public behavior for a safer society.
However, the idea raises serious privacy
concerns. Critics argue it could lead to
a surveillance state with constant
monitoring infringing on personal
privacy rights, while others say it
could help solve crimes faster and
provide transparency to citizens in
cases of excessive force from law
enforcement.
>> We're going to have supervision. In
other words, every police officer is
going to be supervised at all times.
Ellison's proposal highlights a growing
trend among tech giants to harness AI
for societal influence, which may
significantly reshape our lives in the
coming years.
>> Reshape our lives in coming years. Look,
he's trying to sell it to you by saying,
look, cops are going to be better, okay?
Cops are going to be on their best
behavior
because, you know, everybody's kind of
afraid of, oh, what if a cop steps over
his boundaries and all that stuff. So,
he's trying to sell it to you like that,
but he said people will behave when
they're being watched 24/7 by universal
AI governance surveillance system. This
is insane. So, this is this is how it
looks. This is in China right now. It's
been happening for a couple years now.
And look how Orwellian it is.
>> Everywhere she goes, O Yang Haou is
followed. what she buys, how she behaves
is tracked and scored to show how
responsible and trustworthy she is. It's
called the social credit system and in
one version now being tested. A person's
reputation is scored on a scale of 350
to 950. And how you with a good score of
752 is okay with it. In fact, most
people are.
>> It's a mechanism like uh pushes you to
become a better citizen. It's big data
meets big brother, expanding how the
government monitors, understands, and
ultimately controls its 1.4 billion
citizens,
>> thanks to advances in artificial
intelligence and facial recognition and
a web of more than 200 million
surveillance cameras.
>> Are people bothered by privacy concerns?
>> We think the lot of camera
keep the safety is really good. We can
accept it. Companies are experimenting
with the algorithms to help the
government create the new national
social credit system. The government
also has pilot projects. In one,
citizens are required to do hours of
unpaid work to get benefits and scores
are docked for things like littering, a
messy yard, gossip, even jaywalking.
Video of offenders is shown on the local
news
and information collectors like Joey are
paid to report on their neighbors. Her
quota 10 entries a month like the man
who carried a drunk person home. A good
deed. She says good social credit gets
rewarded with perks like cheap loans and
travel deals. But a bad score means
public shame and worse. Hang Jun lost a
court case and didn't pay. Now he's on a
government blacklist.
>> I can't buy airplane or train tickets,
he says. And the list goes on. Being
discredited makes it hard to get a job
or put kids in top schools. The social
credit system will go nationwide next
year and few here are willing to
criticize it. Something that may pose a
risk itself for a bad score and the life
that comes with it. Janice Mackie Fraer,
NBC News, Beijing.
>> So if they even criticize it, they'll
get a bad score. That video clip is from
like two years ago. They're living under
it now. Nationwide. It says in a year
this will be nationwide. What were they
saying? You know, that woman said, you
know, I like it. It helps people be a
good citizen. Why? Because there's
barely any Christianity in China.
Think about that. when the true
Christianity not I'm not talking about
this universal coexist Christianity I'm
talking about
true commandmentkeeping Christians
that's going to be a threat that's going
to be a threat to your salvation to your
Christian walk if you bow to this system
it's the beast system and it's coming
now that one lady was saying that she
gets paid to snitch on people. That
sounds crazy, right? That would never
happen in America. Well, remember co
listen to this.
>> We need to make sure that everybody
continues to let us know where those
folks are. If you've observed recurring
violations of the safer at home order,
please continue to let us know at
coronavirus.acity.org/business
violation. You know the old expression
about snitches? Well, in this case,
snitches get rewards. We want to thank
you for turning folks in and making sure
we are all safe. If you see a business
not abiding by the rules of six feet
stickers on the floor and plexiglass and
wearing masks, then tell on them and you
will get rewarded. Secret police just
like China. It's here in America already
here. That was 5 years ago. Larry
Ellison outlines Oracle's generative AI
strategy. I'm just wanting you to see
that the name of this website is Oracle.
Oracle is the company that is pushing
this or that is creating this Stargate
AI governance system. What is an oracle
by definition? A priest or priestess
acting as a medium through whom advice
or prophecy was sought from the gods in
classical iniquity.
False gods, demons, demonic priest is
the name of this company. That's not a
coincidence. That is purposeful.
Now there is a book called The Great
Controversy written in the 1800s,
possibly the early early 1900s. pretty
sure it was written in the 1800s and it
has such prophetic insight on what's
coming in our world. What I'm trying to
show you with this is this is not a new
idea that we're going to uh be racing
towards a society where it's all about
coexist and it's a one world church that
looks really good. It's about being a
good moral person and accepting people
and doing good deeds.
This is prophetic and people have known
about this for a long time
and it's going to deceive millions of
Christians because a lot of Christians
will will look at it and say, "Well, it
it sounds good. It looks good. It's
about loving people and accepting them
and being tolerant of them." And but
it's going to be a system that goes
against the commandments of God. For
one, all gods aren't the same. And there
are commandments that will be broken by
obeying this beast system, this one
world religion. You're going to a church
with false doctrine that's teaching you
something that the Bible doesn't teach
and it's going to break specific
commandments. So, here's a list of of
how things are going to race towards the
second coming.
There's going to be a moral decline and
chaos, disasters, immorality, and
economic unrest. We already talked about
that. We we see it. You watch the news
and you see riots and protests and you
see uh chaos and disasters. There's
going to be religious unity efforts
among Catholics, Protestants, and
spiritualists. That's happening right
now. You just look at what uh Pope Leo
is talking about. He's talking about
uniting all religions together. He is um
Sunday will be promoted as a moral
solution. Keep that in your mind. We're
going to cover that. Sunday will be
promoted as a moral solution. False
miracles confirm the movement's divine
backing. So once this one world religion
comes and Satan is literally here
manifest as an angel of light doing
lying signs and wonders and miracles,
it's going to deceive millions because
they're going to say, "Well, look, um,
it's got to be true because look, this
being is healing people. This is Jesus."
Popular demand leads to legislation.
It's going to be accepted by the
majority. The majority are going to say
this is a good thing. Sunday law
enforced nationally,
then worldwide. First, it's going to
start in America. Sunday law, and then
it's going to go worldwide.
God's people refuse and face
persecution.
If you follow the commandments of God
that say to
keep the seventh day holy and to
remember it and this system is saying
no, you will be forced to go to the
universal coexist church on Sunday and
you say no, you will be persecuted. You
will be looked at as a hater. You'll be
looked at as intolerant. You'll be
looked at as a thorn in the side of
every person and an enemy of the state.
Final warning will be given, plagues
will fall, and Jesus will return. Here's
what I'm talking about. Pope Leo
promotes interfaith dialogue and unity
for global peace, calling for religions
to collaborate in on justice and
compassion. Not a single world religion
emphasizing shared values while
respecting differences. A stance seen by
some as paving way for global religious
unity.
though he focuses on ecumenicism and
religious freedom, not merging faiths.
So he's right now he's trying to say
we're not really merging them, but we're
we're all just unifying. What's the
difference? Unifying, merging. He
encourages Christian unity, Orthodox and
Catholic, and dialogue with Islam,
Judaism, Buddhis or Hinduism, and
Buddhism, etc. echoing Vatican 2's
Nostra I can't say that aate
but some critics see these efforts as
fulfilling prophecies of a future one
world religion yeah tell me about it I
see it interfaith collaboration actively
brings Christians Jews Muslims Hindus
Buddhists and other leaders together for
peace often referencing the 60th
anniversary of Nostra at Vatican too.
Okay, pay attention.
Bringing all faiths together in the name
of peace in a time of chaos and
calamity. Right? Order out of chaos. The
peace, a false peace. When they say
peace and safety, sudden destruction
comes upon them. Right? Now, look what
just came out. The Heritage Foundation.
Now, who is the Heritage Foundation?
That's a good question. Let's ask that.
Who is the Heritage Foundation?
The Heritage Foundation is an
influential American conservative think
tank based in Washington DC. Founded in
1973, its stated mission is to formulate
and promote public policies based on the
principles of free enterprise, limited
government, individual freedom,
traditional American values, traditional
American values, and a strong national
defense.
It is widely considered one of the most
influential public policy research
institutions in the world. Okay, this is
not just some mom's meeting. Okay, the
Heritage Foundation is the most
influential public policy research in
the world. What are they saying right
now? Saving America. A foundation for
the next 20 250 years. Because America
just celebrated 250 years as a nation.
They're saying, "Look, we want to make
sure that we got another great 250
years. And how are we going to do that?"
They got all kinds of stuff in here. Uh
promarriage, pro-child equals pro-
family. We got marriage on the ropes.
Normalization of unwed childbearing.
Uh having two parents is more than a
privilege. So all this sounds great,
right? like online dating, hookups and
pornography culture. Like they're going
against bad things in society, immoral
things, the war on poverty and marriage.
So, it all sounds really good. Check out
ABC News. Heritage Foundation calls on
us to prioritize marriage and family and
new report. And you scroll through here
and it's talking about, you know, who
they are, what they do. And right here
it says among its recommendations, a
marriage boot camp designed to prepare
cohabitating couples for marriage, a
universal day of rest.
This is what's being talked about right
now, guys. We are there. This is no
longer
a future prophetic thing. This is right
here on point number three. Sunday
promoted as a moral solution. The whole
article that the Heritage Foundation put
out was all about restoring morality to
America. And what do they have on the
list? A universal day of rest. This is
nothing new. It's being talked about by
many different people. These websites
like Green Sabbath Project have been out
for years and they've been pushing this
whole thing about taking a break and how
it goes back to uh you know back to
Genesis and all this stuff, but it's all
about
enforcing
keeping Sunday as a day of rest. Sounds
great, but this is prophetic, guys. A a
green Sabbath. This is taking care of
the environment by taking a day of rest.
Now listen to this guy.
>> Something that something I really
encourage I don't see a big it's harder
to see a big federal role for this. I
think this is more a question of state
and local law is um reinvigorating where
possible Sabbath rest laws. to be very
specific like it used to this was
basically the norm through as best I
looked into this some I'm working on
some research on this um really going
literally dating back to Constantine um
and his recognition of Christianity in
the Roman Empire that you've had a
pretty consistent tradition in in
Western civilization of of taking like
taking Sunday off uh from from commerce
um this of course this is a tradition
that has roots not only in Christianity
but in in Judaism um and and keeping the
Sabbath holy um
>> and having a having a time not only for
it's not merely from rest in the sense
of of of abstinence from work but it's
it's rest for it's rest for time with
God time worshiping God it's rest for
time with community or and even before
in between is time with family um the
the lack one of the things that I think
has been so um so harmful to the world
of work and how we think about work is
the lack of of kind of well-defined and
shared times for rest.
>> Okay, you get the point. He's talking
about we need to reinstate these Sabbath
rest day laws on Sunday, the Sunday law.
He said it goes back to Constantine.
That's exactly right. Constantine was a
pagan, a Roman pagan who enforced that
all shops must be closed on the
venerable day of the sun.
And it's prophesied that it's going to
come back. That's what this book right
here is all about. If you guys want a
copy of The Great Controversy for free,
please
uh email me. You can My email is right
here at the bottom. You see, you can
email info@candtruth.org
or executebrand@gmail.com.
Either one of them will get to me. If
you want a copy of this free book that
prophesied this, I will send you one
absolutely free because this is vital
information.
Um
the fact that they're talking about
these Sunday rest laws. This is Jonathan
Barry. He is a part of the project 2025
thing that Trump said, "Oh, I don't know
anything about project 2025." That's
what he said. He's like, "2025? I don't
know what that is." And in
within a few months, he already had
implemented 41% of the project 2025
agenda.
And now here we are talking about
keeping a day of rest from the Heritage
Foundation. This is here, guys. It's
here. So, what's soon to come? Soon to
come is the elimination of cash. It's
all going to be digital. Get your
digital ID or you don't eat. AI's taking
all your jobs. Um, the high tariffs are
causing layoffs while everyone's losing
jobs and even high paying high paid
people cannot afford day-to-day life.
You're going to have to figure out a way
to survive. And that's where the
universal basic income comes in. All you
got to do, all you got to do, get the
get the digital ID and go to the
universal church and you're going to get
your your uh universal basic income.
You're going to be all good and and the
world's going to be a better place
because AI governs everything. AI is
watching you. AI knows if you went to
church or not. AI knows if you've been
talking about homosexuality as a sin or
that Jesus is the only way.
This is a crazy world about to be in.
We're about to be in a dystopian world.
And I don't think it's any coincidence.
If you guys have not checked out our
channel, go to the live tab, check out
the videos we have on Charlie Kirk. I do
not think it's a coincidence that
another
major event
was pushing towards a book, the sale of
a book that's making Christians think
about keeping a day again. The book was
all about pick your day. It's important
to keep a day because we live in a world
right now where even your average
Christian is not keeping the day holy.
whether it's Saturday or Sunday, they're
going to church and afterwards they're
going out to eat and they're watching
the football game and they're not
keeping it holy. So, this book that just
so happened to be to blow up because the
writer of the book happened to be
assassinated and be looked at as a
martyr.
You guys need to check out the videos,
see why I don't believe the um the
narrative. I don't believe the
mainstream media narrative.
I believe this is all by manufactured
design. This is all on purpose to
promote a book telling you it's
important to keep a day and the Charlie
Kirk effect and everybody's going to
church again and Heritage Foundation is
saying we need to implement implement
Sunday law because the moral decline of
America, it's coming, guys. It's here.
Get ready.
What are you doing to get ready? That's
the question. What am I doing to get
ready? These are the thoughts that I've
had on my mind. This is why I've been
kind of heavy-hearted and just kind of
in a rut. But I got more videos coming
out for you guys. If you like this
video, please give it a thumbs up.
Really helps get this video out into the
algorithm. More people need to know
what's coming so they will stop living
like the days of Noah and the days of
Lot. They'll stop just eating and
drinking and giving in marriage and just
going about life as usual. and they will
begin to get their hearts prepared to
meet Christ because he's coming soon,
guys. But it's not going to happen until
after some very deceptive times of false
miracles and the world looking like it's
getting back to peace and safety and
coexist. It's going to look good on the
surface, but it's completely
anti-biblical. I love you guys. If you
guys want to support this ministry, you
can do so by going to cantruth.org. You
can donate through cash app, Vinmoel,
PayPal. We even have Patreon. We are
100% donationbased. So, if you have been
giving to this ministry, we love you. We
thank you. We cannot do this without
you. And if you like cool merchandise,
we got a store. We get about $5 per sale
on the items there. If you're new to
this channel, please click subscribe so
you don't miss another episode. Share
this with all your family and friends
because the end is near, guys. But Jesus
is coming soon and I want to be ready
when he comes. I love you guys. God
bless. We'll see you next time on Can of
Truth.